buckle up for that temperature roller
coaster and you gotta buckle up for a
big slow down in the southeast that is
finally getting out of the way
and you still have this slowing up on
the i-15 in both directions between
excuse me cheyenne and craig i believe
they have gotten this one out of the way
though it's been there for more than an
hour southbound on the 95.5
very bad crash after sunset now for some
reason this camera has gone way out of
focus but i believe
all traffic lanes are open they were
blocking the three lanes there for a
while
you still have a parking lot back
towards russell roads if you have to be
somewhere in a hurry we're suggesting it
off to 95
at russell go over east to boulder
highway down to warm springs
and it may sound weird to go backwards
on warm springs over to stephanie but
that will get you down to the 215
but bottom line i believe they are
getting this crash out of the way so
those backups
should begin to loosen up here before
too much longer all right you want to
grab your two-tone
shoes because we're going to be going
centennial bowling after the break
what's being done about a specific rank
where the 95 meets the
15. you're watching good day las vegas